hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen to
cover show und natürlich haben wir heute
wieder ein gast und zwar derart hallo
der grafik skelett als gast des sports
irgendwo was teleportiert ich einfach
mal dass ich glaub du bist gespannt beim
box media house kann es sein dass sein
und zwar was ich auch sofort sagen
wollte heute minecraft pocket zu gast
und was ich kurz fragen wollte weil ihr
geht das bei mir gerade ich nutze das 6
ppg kräftig speck und obwohl es euch
einfach ganz gefragt welches wir besser
findet janina kraft das flex für die
schleuse mir ist es egal da ein wildes
skelett ist hier und sonst könne man
einfach sagen
minecraft pocket wir wissen nicht ob die
show so richtig verfolgt hast dich nicht
wir haben das so in planung das du dich
hier bei uns irgendwo die nähe ist also
wie du siehst schau mal eben hier job da
hinten ist wie zum beispiel das haus von
marcus fenix und da hinten kommt hier
hinten steht pop shop medias haus da
dass diese band ist verkörpert diese
wand hier ist von der ic waggons
formiert du kannst jetzt eben wieder
einbauen wo ich hin schlage da sieht es
ganz interessant auch die auf und er und
sagt du dir einfach von den kisten von
topshop wieder nehmen oder von sparks
haus ach ich glaube warum sie so ich
hatte sechs level du hast mich auch
lecker getötet also jetzt da ganz ganz
ruhig war die revanche to vom letzten
mal
ich bin zwar keine level meermann du
hast mich auch getötet ja aber trotzdem
meine erinnert mich jetzt an die hunger
games wir vorhin gespielt haben sind wir
schon beim ersten thema
was für eine überleitung ich bin ich bin
froh dass wir jetzt mit einem zimmer
stehen mein freund bist verfolgten wir
verfolgt immerhin hunger games gespielt
einige folgen sind wahrscheinlich schon
online oder sind auf jeden fall schon
online
gemessen wird gar nicht wie weit wir
schon haben ich hab nichts aufgenommen
doch habe ich ja das habe ich mir nicht
so
diesen diesen diesen minecraft pocket
der kontinent spielt nicht mehr mit der
es total blöd warum ist der blog hier
überhaupt wird doch nicht auf penalty
er macht auch keine minecraft vogels er
macht auch keine minecraft server
tutorials dann macht einfach gar nichts
auf youtube lässt einfach nur irgendwie
auf einmal da gewesen
in freier rede ist hier nicht alle hat
gerät also kariertes länger wir wollten
über hunger games quatschen vorhin also
brauchst du meine ganzen sachen hier
fliegen überall auf dem mac verstreut
ich mache mich jetzt mal auf die suche
wo sind die kisten wo sind die kiste
welche gar nicht ausrauben
so hört wenn du da in meiner klasse geht
nicht um eine ruine sieht auch aus wie
bei hunger games
wir haben hier auch vor ab jetzt müssen
wir jetzt in dieser aufnahme dir machen
leon ein staat ausmachen wo immer alles
hinkommt und jeder sich seine sachen
holen kann jeder gast danke an denen tut
mir das in kommentare geschrieben hat
letztlich weise auch die das vielleicht
haben sie dass wir das gesehen haben
die haben gesagt dass die leute die ihr
bei uns hier neu sind die haben ja nie
irgendwas womit die sich jetzt gegen die
wir bauen können oder so dass die sparte
auch beschwert und deswegen wollten
einfach raus machen wo dann wirklich
auch sich die leute die hier wirklich zu
gast sind die immer sachen nehmen können
und damit dann direkt schon so ein paar
anfangs altem fahrten du kannst jetzt
erst mal was von spark oder von bingens
klauen
ja ich habe mir jetzt leben unseren
zeuge geklaut was überhaupt nicht
brauche aber egal egal wo wissen du wird
sonst immer holz fällen gehen wo bin ich
das mal in dem walter hier ist weil der
weiter hier ist er als künstlich
es wäre natürlich der walter dabei lag
es also ich hätte schon gespielt ich
hätte zum beispiel samplings völlig und
bei mir gar nichts für dich doch du
kannst aber sie bleiben bitte da unten
hallo ich wollte eine menge tiere
abholen die intellektuellen luft
geflogen
so was sieht das kann auch sehr
zweideutig ausdehnen wenn du hier so
weit herunter immer das was man sich
denken möchte oder eine blume für dich
bitte sehr
er braust irgendwie werkzeuge das so
brauche ich nicht brauche ich muss alles
daran sich franz werkzeuge die natürlich
ja doch noch was von tennisbällen ich
bin hier eine pussy deswegen porsch
werkzeuge
okay die ist was kaputt ika zu haben und
siehe da musst du selber machen
es lag einmal dieses kaputt egal ich
gemäß von irgendjemand was ich lag
einmal die kaputt
diesmal will die gastfreundlich wir sind
in der today show muss man eben beispiel
als stopp ein vorhand so geht's nicht
nein nein lass das ist wieder zurück
also jetzt schnell mitgenommen aber habt
kein redstone ist nein gibt zurückgibt
zurückgibt rücken terroristin minecraft
bakijews ausgenommen bringst du bringst
du so nicht erwartet welch ein ganz
liebes e mail mit dem so geht's nicht so
ist nicht das was macht sie nachhaltig
genommen rum husten sich auf meiner spur
hat sich orientiert ist es raus genommen
nein da hab ich nicht zum äußersten
greifen
ich glaube ich zum äußersten greifen da
führt kein weg dran vorbei
so stehen geblieben es gibt keinen
ausweg du kannst du mir sprinten ja ja
nicht mehr lange vor der weizen
wir haben eine große weit zu fahren ja
aber die man längst auf denkste etwa
jetzt nicht meinen schönen sandstein hat
außerdem aus sind aus dem tempel geholt
habe
und gold als ich geholt also so geht's
nicht
jetzt bin ich so im inventar von dir und
ich hab dir noch sachen geschenkt bitte
wieder zurück bist du so nah kommen
wollt dann nicht so wie minecraft pocket
doch gerade zu benehmen wie minecraft
pocket ich mach das gut so selbstlos
oder vertiefen ich kann ihnen die sachen
die auf dem vesuv eröffnet habe ich mir
alles gesammelt was hast du mehr als
geklaut
es ist ja auch wieder seine kreise
leon wir haben eine welt und jetzt sind
einfach keine kühe jetzt an bischöfe
aber
das einfach machen wir keine scharfen
das blöde gut da will ich nicht einfach
nur das akku aber nur eine die bringt
mir nix macht 0 oder 2
die kuh vom grund geklaut dem debakel
hat dann ist paula paul paula ist die
art flecken irgendwie so walter baco
phoenix hat style muss ich sagen warum
das hauptgleis hat er gut eingerichtete
ich gute arbeit
ja stimmt ja auch so und jetzt gleich
schon mal irgendwo beisicht gebaut und
hat mir gesagt er möchte jetzt allgemein
schönere sachen in minecraft bauen
bei mir hat das funktionieren also meint
als unverbesserlich schön es ist ein ic
waggons habe ich wunderschön getroffen
da darf ich dann schon ein bisschen
stein aus einer kiste neben vielen dank
aus meiner
und dann stehst du halt gleich und ganz
ohne hast du überhaupt schon holt ja ja
das habe ich mir von ihr geklaut ich
wirklich sagen dass dinge und ich wir
bauen gleich erstmal so ein kleines
häuslicher heußlein und mir dann ein
paar items einlegen die leute haben
können also von der anderen hand nehmen
pflicht besorgnis
ich habe mich hab mich jetzt hier
einfach mal hin gepflanzt vielleicht
kann jemand gucken kommen
ich hab ne coole hinter mir das abrufen
kann dann kommen sie alle verwirren
dann wissen sie nicht will dort wo bist
du ein 1 1 zum schönen landschaft ist
die ganze aussicht verzichtet so einfach
deine bilder sehe wieder runterzukommen
und texten
je nach konzept mit den kühen die wollen
hier nicht rein
ok warte website ist drin eine schon
drin ist drin die arbeiten wohl ähnlich
gewaltig muss kurz einmal minecraft
paket töten der irgendwie auf dem server
gekommen aber muss einmal hier weg doch
ich komme
die zweite ist drin
viel spaß noch in den nächsten sieben
folgen darum drei tage sind vergangen
vier tage so was nicht bei den hunger
games da wenn ihr da beim ersten bei der
ersten folge von mir ich bin in der
hilft falle geraten
aber ich bin nicht gestorben ich habe
noch gelebt so kam aber nicht mehr
heraus
ich hätte ewig warten können unter wert
gewonnen was macht minecraft pocket er
tötet mich ich beziehung hilfe mich aus
zu teleportieren was macht ihr hilfe
auch ja sterbehilfe passt nämlich so
geht's nicht
ich habe kein walzen alter wenn ich eine
menge schnäppchen das auch gut und
creeper dahin darf ich dich erst gerade
gemacht ok scheiße ich brauche auch
wolle ja was du hast da ist erster noch
ein schaf schon wieder auch einspruch
aber ganz viel holz wenn ich geh mal
holz finde das eine gute idee dass die
kübel du musst die kühe vermehren hast
du ein bisschen so ein bisschen die
können nicht mehr total war erst ein
paar tage pause also wir auch schon
mitbekommen habt ihr dieser folge kein
thema über das wir quatschen einfach ein
bisschen bange games neuer gast und so
weiter alles der spd als kanzler dass
minecraft letztes in den neuen mob
hinzugefügt hinzugefügt hat ja ich
glaube da ist ja gerade eine komische
figuren ja voll den komischen namen
alle darüber beschwert irgendwas mit
minecraft oder im eimer oder sowas ja
genau einmal beschreibt ihn eigentlich
ziemlich genau so ein ziemlich eimer
jetzt kommt an land beleidigt eure gäste
ja nur noch das alte total böse er übels
nein also dein haus bisher liegt sehr
gut ausführlich
er passt auf guck mal ich bin echt gut
pass auf ich baue ich baue jetzt hier
mal schnell ein haushälter von sapphire
also nicht nach hause sondern zum werfen
ich glaube so ein witz habe ich auch
irgendwann mal gebracht hat sei das
gewesen
das haus hatte gebracht da gab es auch
die lacher auf seiner seite als du noch
so ein witzeerzähler zwei münchen
pass auf ich mein haus ist fast fertig
die sind so süß
ach du scheiße sexszene wartet einmal
kurz bild gesamterlöse unterschied das
haus ja echt sind auch sehr schlecht
schön schön übrigen er unternimmt auch
mit auf allerdings wahrscheinlich lädt
er das nicht alles sondern nur so
highlights oder halt gar nix also muss
man noch genauer internet bei ich hab
sogar holz leitung bei mir zu hause
ich habe als altholz leitung
sie hat etwas kann nicht ewig dass
hierbei aber irgendwas baue ich gerade
auf jeden fall wollten auf jeden fall
noch mal im bansen wolle turm bauen weil
ich schon sieben ins ziel wolle habe er
solche jetzt soll ich euch irgendwie
helfen oder schafft ihr das alleine zu
waschen
du bist in der gast gar nicht so zu
helfen
ich will zuerst im selben haus moral
also wenn ich groß bin möchte gerne dass
er mir das haus baute also das ist
verstehe ich und der gastfreundschaft
halt stopp nein jetzt reicht es nicht
für notwendig so geht's nicht halt jeder
mal mal an wie lange wir uns schon auf
somit schon der zweiten folge wir sind
in ein paar sekunden letzten folgen so
excited und dann haben auch schon wieder
eine frage darauf spielte ich an
doch was darum geht darum spielt ich an
spielt die hp-spitze fenster hamburger
spitze jetzt endlich auch richtig geld
und der typ grad gegessene der thermal
doch wieso im riesenvogel zehn minuten
oder skelette ich bin zum essen bestimmt
dann also freiheit sprach platz alles
rein
ich habe keines glatt mit dem baum
verwechselt